honey we are here at games people we are
here at Gamescom 2015 and I'm joined by
Lucy James who has played quantum break
you are what we are here at Gamescom
2015 I am joined by Lucy James who saw
quantum break Lucy what is quantum break
you are I did beep caught reference well
tell me about quantum break we'll worry
about lost and later okay so quantum
break so it had its in it but we reveal
at the Microsoft press briefing on
Tuesday and it looks like a third-person
cover shooter you're not wrong yes but
the story's a little more complex I
think partly because it has a TV show
attached to it which I'll explain later
because now I know how that's gonna turn
traveling and it's not time travel so
it's not gonna be an easy thing to kind
of explain who Sam like himself Max
Payne Randolph was that he did a great
job of explaining so basically the main
character Jack Joyce who is Shawn
Ashmore from x-men not from x-men from
real life well he plays Bobby in x-men I
just assume he's a mega level mutant at
all times
hey his brother will he's played by
Dominic Monaghan
everyone's favorite hobbit slash you
know lost yeah island dweller his
brother is a scientist he physically
like having his role if you remember the
lot short-lived TV show flash-forward
yeah his scientist he's meddling with
time and at the University
is obviously an accident stuff goes
wrong with time out their friend who's
played by Aiden Gillen Littlefinger from
Game of Thrones it's like some weird
time thing happened gets sent into the
future and that's why he looks
considerably older 17 years older in
fact that his friends when he comes back
he is a head of the evil guys monarchy
and he what he does is he actually kills
don't wanna hand wills character so Jack
Joyce so you pay his brother you play
brother so it's kind of like a party a
tail for a revenge revenge and also but
the thing that it's a tale about
different philosophies Jack Joyce also
has the power to manipulate time so to
get into so he believes that the future
is not set in stone and wants to do
everything that he kind of change it and
you know in a way like bring his brother
back and yeah everyone atop the ever
after aiding killings character Paul
he's seen the future he's very it's very
deterministic we're living on it's gonna
happen there's nothing we can do about
it so if these two warring philosophies
and that's kind of how the game set up
clash of ideologies that all ultimately
comes to blow in color vase shooting
yeah is that right
what's happening is that because time is
messed up there are these time like
stutters which is what we've been seeing
in the gameplay trailers we're just
waking up and so Jack Joyce and Paul can
both manipulate these things the evil
guys could also manipulate because they
have a thing on their bank that helps
them manipulate to a certain degree but
not as powerful ago T so that's why they
can fire at you
like bubbles of fire things like that so
that's how they can do that but time I
think it's unaffected for people who
aren't wearing those who aren't the main
characters so in terms of like the
people talking to you is like
platforming which reminded me a little
bit of uncharted and one that might have
been because it was set in a shipping
yard so what was happening is times
freaking out and you're using your time
power so either - past something before
it falls on you
or too slow something down or you can we
can set up like a burst of time it's
like a destructive thing to make
something crumble that you can climax so
you're telling me using those same
powers that you would use in combat in
platforming exactly what about the show
okay so I understand how it works now so
I'm genuine more excited about so the
game is from the perspective of Jack
Jones from the protagonist and the hero
the show is the Vilnius and also there's
a lot of overlap right so the way it's
gonna work is that you play an act of
the game and the only actor that you
make a choice and depending on a choice
you made you need to get a different
episode of the show so the episodes are
gonna be running between only about 22
minutes they were saying like a regular
half-hour show in America without ads
and of course it's all depended on the
choice you've made the show yeah there's
characters scenery and actual scenes
that overlap so we saw one bit from the
TV show where these two characters were
you know pointing gun each other things
are getting heated Jack Joyce was locked
up in the back of a fan but then what
happened is because they weren't wearing
their Manik things they were you know
time just passed smoothly for them and
at one point their guns were missing and
Jack dose was missing
but then in the game you actually play
that scene as Jack Joyce and you you
basically manipulate time take that gun
to bring yourself and get out so it's
really cool to see the way they overlap
I'm definitely intrigued in the kind of
the connectivity between them the whole
thing like time travel and the butterfly
effect sounds convoluted as well I'm
always worried about time travel yeah
because there's always like the failsafe
let's just go back before this all
happened
so I'm kind of hoping that doesn't
happen but the game looked really good
like physics in it were amazing
just like stuff freaking out in time
there's one thing you can can rely on
remedy for it's good action set-pieces
and good combat and from what I've seen
it looks amazing in that department but
we'll find out more about in the future
until then keep your eyes on games
father home for more coverage from
Gamescom
you